bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire le numéro 15
est aujourd'hui nous aborderons
l'analyse de survie alors j'espère que
vous allez bien
aujourd'hui on va avancer sur des
techniques d'analysé un peu plus poussée
et notamment l'analyse de survie le
principe de l'analyse de survie c'est
d'étudier l'eau la survenue d'un
événement d'antan et donc du coup on va
avoir besoin de deux dates une date
origines c'est à dire une date à partir
de laquelle on va commencer à regarder
le phénomène qui nous intéresse et puis
on va regarder quand est ce que ce
produit
notre phénomène d'intérêt et aujourd'hui
nous allons prendre pour exemple la
question de la mortalité infanto
juvénile c'est à dire la mortalité avant
5 ans à partir de données qui vont
ressembler à des données typique que
l'on aurait dans une enquête
démographique et de santé en afrique
subsaharienne
on va tout d'abord déjà basculé sous
verre donc vous êtes maintenant habite
fait à l'interface de leur studio
là j'ai déjà créé un nouveau un nouveau
projet pour aujourd'hui et les données
qui vont nous servir aujourd'hui
proviennent du package kouchner donc on
va déjà chargé les données en mémoire
pour voir à quoi il ressemble je vais
créer un nouveau script
et donc aujourd'hui nous allons aborder
l'analyse de survie je vais sauvegarder
mon script on va charger quiz steiner et
donc on va charger les données qui sont
accessibles dans un jeu de données qui
s'appelle data fécondité donc si on
charge data fécondité après avoir chargé
quiz tonnerre vous voyez apparaître
trois tableaux dans votre dans votre
environnement le tableau enfants le
tableau femmes et le tableau ménages on
va tout de suite chargé le taille
diverse qui va nous servir tout du long
et puis je vais également chargé le
package label d' pour l'avoir sous la
main
alors regardons rapidement à quoi
ressemble fichiers en font donc le
fichier en font c'est un fichier qui
contient 1584 entrées pour six variables
on a une variable identifiants de
l'enfant une variable y des femmes qui
correspond à l'identifiant de la mer une
variable date de naissance le sexe de
l'enfant
est ce que l'enfant est il toujours en
vie et un âge au décès dans le cas où
l'enfant n'a pas survécu donc si jamais
l'enfant n'ait pas envie on va avoir un
âge au décès exprimée en moi si je
regarde un peu plus rapidement dans la
console
on voit que nos variables sont ici codé
sous la forme de données labellisé a
envoyé deiber plus la belle qui apparaît
pour sexe et sur vie autrement dit pour
la variable sexe et pour la variable
survie le type d'objet ce sont des
vecteurs labellisé nous
déjà abordé c'est le type de vecteurs
que l'on obtient lorsque l'on apporte un
fichier spss stata ou saas avec heaven
ici j'utilise look fort on peut voir les
codes utilisés
donc là on va avoir un sexe de l'enfant
un pur masculins 2 pour féminin et
l'enfant at il toujours en vie zéro non
un oui si je vais regarder si j'ai des
données manquantes en fichiers on peut
utiliser la fonction frais kenna qui est
fournie par cautionnaire et qui me
permet d'avoir une idée du nombre de
valeurs manquantes
alors j'ai des valeurs manquantes sur
l'âge au décès en même temps c'est
normal puisque l'ajout des scènes et
renseigne que pour ceux qui sont décédés
et on va avoir du coup aucune valeurs
manquantes sur les autres variables
d'intérêt maintenant pour vous présenter
plus globalement l'anc est donc les
données que vous avez ce sont deux
données qui sont typiques et une enquête
démographique et de santé
donc les enquêtes démographiques et de
santé ce sont des enquêtes qui sont
menées auprès des ménages vous avez donc
on va visiter un certain nombre de
ménages on va avoir un questionnaire
ménage puis dans chacun de ces ménages
on va conduire un questionnaire auprès
de toutes les femmes adultes présents
dans le ménage et ensuite pour chacune
de ces femmes
on va demander des informations sur
toutes leurs histoires génésique donc
surtout leurs enfants et c'est pour ça
qu'on se retrouve avec trois fichier un
fichier en font un fichier femme un
fichier ménage donc le fichier ménages
regardons le rapidement le be contient
les variables collectées au niveau du
ménage
on a un identifiant ménage une taille de
ménage c'est le nombre de personnes
vivant dans le ménage le sexe du chef de
ménage
la structure du ménage donc est ce que
c'est un ménage à deux adultes de sexe
opposé adultes sans lien de parenté
trois adultes ou plus avec liam parents
terre donc on a une structure
démographique du ménage et puis on a
enfin un niveau de richesse
pauvres très pauvres moyens riches ou
très riche donc en cinq niveaux
donc ça c'est une variable que l'on
retrouve régulièrement dans les enquêtes
en afrique subsaharienne
comme il est difficile de mesurer les
revenus d'un ménage avec précision on va
plutôt collecter tout un certain nombre
d'indicateurs comme le type de toit le
type de bâti le type de sol les
possessions du ménage sur différents
items donc on va avoir une vingtaine
trentaine quarantaine de questions qui
vont traduire les biens possédés par le
ménage à partir desquels est réalisée en
général une analyse factorielle et le
score sur le premier axe de l'analyse
factorielle va servir à déterminer un
score de richesse ou de pauvreté qu'on
va ensuite divisé en 5 quintile enfin
nous avons le fichier femmes donc là
avec les données qui sont collectés pour
chacune des femmes
on a en l'occurrence d'enficher
d'exemple un d'identifiants des femmes y
des femmes
donc on l'avait vu cet identifiant femme
on le retrouve dans fichiers enfants un
d'identifiants ménages que l'on retrouve
dans le fichier ménage un poids
statistiques que l'on va oublier pour ce
soir histoire de faire plus simple une
date d'entretien la date de naissance de
la femme son âge son milieu de résidence
urbain rural la région du moins la
grande région qui en l'occurrence est
codé si on regarde avec le confort la
région est codé en nord est sud et ouest
donc c'est on ajuste diviser le pays en
en quatre grandes régions un niveau
d'éducation
aucun primaire secondaire au supérieur
le fait d'avoir un emploi un statut
matrimonial célibataire marié en
concubinage veuves divorcées séparées la
religion et puis des variables
d'exposition médias lis la presse écoute
la radio regarde la télévision
on a également une question qui est quel
est le nombre d'enfants idéal tel que
perçu par les différentes femmes avec
deux valeurs manquantes qu'ils sont 96 à
et enfin une question sur le test de
dépistage du vih pour savoir si les
femmes ont déjà fait un test aujourd'hui
ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est à partir de ce fichier d'étudier
la mortalité infanto juvénile donc nous
nous intéressons à la mortalité entre 0
et 5 ans exact petit rappel le
démographe quand on parle d âge exact on
sait les âges avec les décimales les
virgules derrière les nombres et donc à
la différence de ce qui l âge révolu où
l'ajout dernière anniversaire donc quand
on parle de la mortalité entre 0 et 5
ans exact
il s'agit de la mortalité entre 0 et 4
ans révolus
une petite nuance quand on parle d âge
mais là c'est le démographe qui va
parler donc ce que l'on va essayer de
faire c'est de regarder donc cette
survie des enfants entre 0 et 5 ans puis
de regarder si la survie des enfants
entre 0 et 5 ans diffèrent entre les
jeunes filles et les jeunes et les
jeunes garçons donc une analyse by
variés et enfin nous essaierons de voir
dans le cas d'une analyse multivariée de
regarder plusieurs facteurs à la fois le
sexe de l'enfant le milieu de résidence
le niveau de vie du ménage
la structure du ménage le niveau
d'éducation de la mer
l'âge de la mère à la naissance et puis
pour compliquer un petit peu les choses
on va essayer de calculer une variable
qui serait de savoir si le rang de
naissance de l'enfant
si c'est le deuxième ou troisième est
supérieur ou non en nombre idéal
d'enfants selon un maire on pourrait se
dire que si une femme considère que le
nombre idéal d'enfants et 2,3 et qu'il
s'agit du quatrième du cinquième enfant
c'est à dire d'un enfant qui
arriveraient après ce nombre idéal
peut-être que cette perception pourrait
avoir un impact en matière de mortalité
et donc maintenant que nous avons chargé
les données et bien eu la plus grosse
partie du travail va être de préparer
ces données et de les recoller
[Musique]
donc ici en l'occurrence notre sujet
principal c'est la mortalité des enfants
de notre unité danalyse cela va être du
coup les enfants tels qu'on les observer
dans l'anc est donc notre unité valises
c'est bien ces niveaux enfants même si
on va devoir aller chercher des
variables qui se situe au niveau du
ménage ou au niveau des mers notre
l'événement qui nous intéresse puisque
dans une analyse sur il faut un
événement qui peut avoir lieu alors on
est dans l'analyse de survie classique
c'est-à-dire un événement qui ne peut
avoir lieu qu'une seule fois
on ne peut pas prendre en compte des
événements répété à ce stade l'événement
que nous allons analyser c'est le décès
et cet événement là il est mesuré à
partir de la variable de qui est mesuré
dans fichiers enfants qui me dit si un
enfant a survécu ou non si un enfant n'a
pas survécu on a donc un événement décès
sauf que dans l'analyse survie on
cherche pas simplement à savoir si les
gens ont des cd ou non ce qu'on va
chercher c'est à mettre ça en fonction
du temps donc on analyse un événement
aux fonctions d'une durée et donc cette
notion de durée dans l'analyse de survie
nécessite de penser une date origine
donc là en l'occurrence ce que l'on va
regarder c'est l'âge au décès c'est
l'âge au décès c'est à dire la durée
entre la naissance et la survenue d'un
décès notre événement origines et donc
pour chacun des enfants
sa date de naissance alors ce qui ce qui
va falloir que l'on prenne en compte de
notre analyse c'est la question de la
censure à droite tous les enfants que je
vais avoir dans mon enquête n'ont pas
forcément encore cinq ans là nous on va
s'intéresser au décès entre 0 et 5 ans
mais si un enfant est né il y a dix mois
et qu'il est toujours en vie
nous savons qu'il n'est pas décédé entre
0 et 10 mois mais nous ne savons rien
de ce qui pourrait lui arriver après là
je dis moi il va falloir donc que l'on
tienne compte de la durée d'observation
pour prendre en compte correctement
cette notion de censure à droite et tout
l'intérêt de l'analyse survie c'est de
pouvoir gérer correctement ces censures
à droite si je regardais directement le
pourcentage qui a survécu
en ne tenant pas compte de cette censure
à droite je vais surestimé la survie
puisque certains n'ont pas encore eu le
temps de pouvoir décédé alors pour pour
cela le premier élément va être on va
déjà avoir besoin de calculer une
variable que je vais appeler la durée
d'observation la durée d'observation
c'est la durée entre la naissance de
l'enfant et la date de l'enquète et ça
va me dire combien de temps nous avons
observé cet enfant là puisque les
événements que nous avons mesuré dans l'
enquête ce sont ceux que nous avions
connaissance au moment là du raid
enquête
nous devons si choisir l'unité de temps
dans laquelle réaliser notre enquête
notre analyse on peut faire l'analyse en
année en jours en semaines
si vous vous souvenez quand je vous ai
présenté alors dans le fichier enfants
je vais retourner dans la console si on
regarde le fichier enfants dans le
fichier enfants l'âge au décès est
exprimée en mois révolus c'est à dire
qu'on connaît l'âge au décès d enfants
exprimé en moi c'est donc notre plus
petit pas de temps qui sera disponible
et donc du coup ce que je vous suggère
c'est qu'on va faire tout notre analyse
en moins donc première étape calculer la
durée d'observation en moins je dispose
en fichiers enfants la date de naissance
qui est ma date origine par contre la
question de la date dans kate n'est pas
renseigné d'un fichier enfant est en
fait cette information là elle est
renseigné dans les fichiers femmes
puisque dans ce fichier femme je dispose
d'une 20
ap qui datent entretien ou date de
passation du questionneur donc première
étape il s'agit d'aller récupérer dans
le fichier enfants l'information date
d'entretien pour ça on prend notre
fichier enfants et on va faire une
jointure pour récupérer les informations
d'un autre fichier et plus
spécifiquement on va faire ce qu'on
appelle une jointure à gauche ce que
l'on obtient avec la fonction lève tôt
john que nous avions déjà abordé
quelle est l'idée de la jointure à
gauche c'est qu'on va compléter toutes
les lignes du fichier enfants par les
informations disponibles du deuxième
fichier d'ajouts mais uniquement pour
ces lignes la la je vais faire une
jointure avec le fichier femmes
mais si les femmes n'ont pas d'enfant je
ne veux pas que ça augmente non de
lignon fichiers enfants ce qui
m'intéresse à cette étape là c'est de
conserver le même nombre de lignes dans
le fichier enfants et on va se doter en
mémoire que notre fichier enfants
contient en tout 1584 observation donc
je prends mon fichier enfants et je vais
faire un left the joy qu'est ce que je
veux récupérer je veux donc récupérer la
variable date entretien du fichier
femmes
je vais donc prendre le fichier femme et
comme je ne veux pas tout récupérer je
vais prendre un select pour indiquer
uniquement les variables qui m'intéresse
ici en l'occurrence la variable date
entretien mais il me faut également la
variable y des femmes qui lavent a rien
qui va parler de faire le lien entre le
fichier en fonte et le fichier femmes
donc je vais donc prendre femme select y
des femmes date entretien ce qui va me
renvoyer un tableau qui ne contient que
deux variables l'identifiant des femmes
ela d'entretien que je vais appliquer
enlève de john officier enfants en
indiquant by égale y des femmes pour
préciser la variable de lien entre les
deux tables
si je fais ceci et que je regarde le
fichier en fonds obtenus
déjà je peux vérifier que j'ai bien
toujours 1584 observations donc je n'ai
pas changé mon hôte d'observation et ça
c'est lié au fait que l'identifiant
femmes dans le fichier femme et un
identifiant unique et j'ai bien récupéré
la variable date d'entretien si je le
fais un petit look fort on voit bien
j'ai récupéré cette variable en plus les
deux variables sont des variables de
type date
je vais donc pouvoir calculer une durée
entre ces deux dates
et comme nous l'avons déjà commencé à
l'aborder précédemment pour gérer faire
de calculs sur les dates
le package du taille diverse appropriée
c'est le package le britain's par défaut
un air si on n'utilise pas lui [ __ ] est
un jeu ses fonctions de base en r
lorsqu'on fait la soustraction entre
deux dates ce que l'on obtient c'est une
différence en jour
nous ce qui nous intéresse est une
différence ambre ce qui est compliqué
quand on travaille sur les dates c'est
que tous les mois n'ont pas forcément la
même longueur certains mois en 28 jours
certains - en 29 jours certains - en 31
jours et donc faire simplement une
différence en jour puis / tranquille ne
nous donnerait pas un calcul vraiment
exact
fort heureusement lui [ __ ] tu es là
pour nous fournir les éléments pour
faire ce travail là à notre place ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'hybride est à plusieurs types d'objets
et notamment un des uns des objets que
que défini lui [ __ ] de ce sont des
objets intervalle un intervalle ça
définit un élément entre deux dates
donc je vais commencer et on va passer
par un mieux être
ce que je vais faire je vais faire
l'intervalle l'observation et donc
j'appelle la fonction intervalle de
l'hybride est et je lui donne une date
de début et une date de fin l'art
l'occurrence ce qui nous intéresse c'est
l'intervalle entre la date de naissance
et la date d'entretien regardons comment
se présente cet objet intervalle
observation en fait chaque entrée c'est
pas toujours bien visibles
mais si je regarde que la première
rentrée annonce que sa vente n y c'est
une période de temps définie par deux
dates en l'occurrence le 13 mars 2010 au
3 mars 2012
à partir de cet intervalle il devient
possible de calculer une durée grâce à
la fonction timeline et donc on va
calculer durée observations et garde 100
m l'elfe de mon interview d'observation
si on regarde rapidement ce que l'on
obtient
voyez on a des chiffres qui sont
relativement élevés parce que par défaut
les intervalles sont calculées en
seconde
si je regarde l'aide time life on a un
paramètre qui unit qui permet d'indiquer
le type en fait l'intervalle qui nous
intéresse est donc ici on va indiquer il
unit tu les gardes manche mais voyez
j'ai maintenant des intervalles ont des
durées d'observation qui sont exprimés
en moi ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
ce que fait time life pour tenir compte
du fait que tous les mois on n'est pas
forcément la même durée en fait ce qui
calcule c'est un conte pour appeler un
âge exact du point de vue démographique
avec toute la partie des civils ce que
l'on fait c'est que ce que va calculer
timelife pour cet intervalle sais si je
m'intéresse par exemple à l'intervalle
entre le 15 mars et le 15 juin
ces deux et le 17 juin par exemple c'est
de regarder déjà les dates anniversaires
c'est à dire du 15 mars au 17 juin le
dernier anniversaire ici en moi puisque
on s'intéresse en vain serait le 15 juin
et donc de mars à juin
du 15 mars au 15 juin nous attend donc
avril mai juin trois mois et donc ça ça
va déterminer la partie entière est pour
maintenant déterminer la partie des six
mêmes et bien du 15 juin au 17 juin
on va avoir deux jours on va calculer le
nombre de jours entre le 15 juin et le
15 juillet là en l'occurrence et 30
jours et donc la partie décimales ça
sera 2 / 30
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'en
utilisant timeline vous n'avez pas à
vous occuper de cette histoire
d'intervalle un peu compliqué à tout
effet automatiquement directement par
par lui [ __ ] qui va gérer les histoires
d'année bissextile qui va gérer les
durées aléatoire mais on a vraiment un
âge exact qui est à la fois continuer en
même temps respecter les dates
anniversaires alors là je vous ai créé
une variable intervalle observation
histoire de vous montrer un ce type
d'objets mais dans les faits ce j'en ai
pas vraiment besoin ce qui m'intéresse
c'est uniquement la durée d'observation
donc ce que je vais faire c'est plutôt
que de créer cette variable là je vais
mettre ma définition d'intervalle
directement à l'intérieur et donc je
verrai réécrire les choses un petit peu
différemment juste présenté comme ça je
vais dire que du coup dur observation
ces intervalles d'être naissance d'un
entretien que je passe à tomlinson
hitman
alors si je regarde cet intervalle on va
faire un sommellerie deux enfants durée
observations on voit qu'en moyenne les
enfants étaient observés pendant 28 mois
donc c'est à dire que pour une majorité
d'enfants nous n'avons pas deux observe
c'est un camp d'observation puisque cinq
ans d'observations ça représenterait 60
mois on voit que la durée d'observation
maximum ses 60 moi ça veut dire que tu
es enquête en fait on a fait l'histoire
génésique unif uniquement des enfants
âgés de moins de cinq ans par contre on
a un certain nombre d'observations qui
sont des durs et d'observation qui sont
négatives et on voit que cette durée
négative elle n'excède jamais un mois
c'est le minimum c'est -0 77 alors on a
une durée négative parce que quand on a
un intervalle ou date de naissance est
après da d'entretien on obtient du coup
une durée négative on a et plus
précisément on a onze enfants qui sont
nés après la date banquette
si je veux regarder le
nombreux là il suggère de faire enfants
fini tard durée observations inférieures
à zéro
[Musique]
summer eyes bas tout simplement la
fonction quand donc j'ai onze enfants
qui ont une durée d'observation négative
ici on est obligé de faire un nettoyage
et de faire une correction
il y a plusieurs manières de procéder
elles vont être vraiment dépendante de
vos données de la connaissance que vous
avez de l'anc est une possibilité ce
serait d'exclure ses onze enfants de
l'analyse puisque pour une analyse
survie vous ne pouvez pas avoir
d'observation de durée d'observation
négative une autre possibilité si c'est
une enquête sur laquelle vous travaillez
en tant que tel ça serait de retrouver
les questionnaires papier et de voir si
à un moment donné ça peut être
simplement des erreurs de saisie
enfin une dernière possibilité puisque
là nous ne pouvons pas retourner au
questionnaire papier pour faire du
nettoyage dans la base de données c'est
de se dire si c'était carlin qui est de
quelques jours peut être lié à la
manière dont sont faites les enquêtes
sur le terrain dans une enquête de type
ménages vous avez une 1ère visite
et pendant cette première visite vous
allez remplir le questionnaire ménages
et puis faire le recensement de
l'ensemble des membres du ménage
et puis souvent à certains membres du
ménage ne sont pas présents vous allez
repasser un petit peu plus tard pour
continuer l enquête ce qui se passe avec
parfois les enquêteurs
plutôt que de près remplissent en fait
leur questionnaire individuel à ce
moment-là et met du coup comme da
d'entretien la date de passation de
l'enquète ménages et non pas la date
réelle quand ils vont revenir un peu
plus tard et donc dans ce cas là il ya
si jamais vous avez le jour 2 le jour de
l'enquète ménages vous avez une femme
qui n'est pas présente parce qu'elle est
en train d'accoucher vous la voyez deux
semaines plus tard
et du coup elles accouchent et depuis
vous vous retrouvez qu'une date de
naissance qui va se retrouver décalé de
quelques jours
après une date d'en quête puisqu'en fait
on a interrogé la femme le 28 mars nous
on avait mis une date dans quête au 2
mars
lorsqu'on était venu faire l' enquête
ménages dans tous les cas il va falloir
procéder à une correction si j'exclus
ses enfants de l'analyse ce qui risque
d'être embêtant c'est que je peut
impacter le calcul du rang de naissance
puisque du coup ils sont plus ils sont
plus dans la base il n'y a pas de
réponse unique
nous ce que l'on va faire dans le cas
présent c'est simplement de rajouter un
mois on va considérer que si jamais la
date d'entretien se situe avant la date
de naissance on va corriger la date
d'entretien et considérer que
l'entretien a lieu un mois plus tard ce
qui va permettre de corriger prennent
que l'on rencontre ça c'est un choix
nettoyage que l'on fait ici
ce qu'il faut retenir et je le répèterai
jamais assez le dit why âge dépend
vraiment de la situation particulière de
votre enquête
alors ce qu'on va faire c'est donc je
vais prendre le fichier enfants
[Musique]
je vais faire à millau tate alors on
pourrait utiliser la fonction à pour
coder on pourrait utiliser la fonction
ifs à ifs france
là j'en prends une autre un petit peu
différente mais qui est un peu plus
simple qui est oblique cote iif qui est
une fonction disponible dans le package
label d'1 on lui passe un vecteur on a
dit qu'une condition et si jamais c'est
juste eh ben on indique la correction
c'est une manière un peu plus simple
d'écrire une reco diffic à sion que de
passer par le fn mais c'est une manière
aussi pour moi de vous présenter
du coup une autre petite fonction qu'on
n'avait pas encore vu donc ce que l'on
va corriger ces dates
entretien donc oui code if donc j'ai
partir de date
entretien que je vais passer agricole y
faire puisque le premier élément
lecteurs arrco d eelv indiqué une
condition alors si dur et observations
ou du moins plus précisément six dates
entretien est situé avant date naissance
[Musique]
alors je vais rajouter un mois à date
entretien
[Musique]
une première manière de dire qu'on veut
rajouter un mois nous avons vu que dans
le bruit des avions des objets de type
intervalles et nous avons aussi des
objets des types durer et si je fais ma
meuf 1 que j'obtiens pour vous montrer à
part on sait pas me manque un saignement
mfa avec un s donc m'en fous un avec un
s génère un objet de type période
si vous regardez la classe de l'objet
c'est un objet de type période et on
peut du coup faire des opérations
mathématiques avec des objets de
tibériade où vous avez membres pour des
mois heroes pour des années des pour des
jours donc c'est une manière de stocker
une durée non pas uniquement en seconde
mais en nombre d'années nombre de jours
nombre d'heures nombre de minutes et
c'est ce qui se passe c'est que si
jamais je fais l'opération date
entretien +91 on peut avoir parfois des
soucis et je vous montre un exemple
concret si je prends la fonction y md
pour faire un objet date je vais faire
le on va dire le 31 janvier 2020 donc
avec eric mt jeu peut transformer une
chaîne de textes en objet date si jamais
je lui rajoute trois jours
pas de souci 31 janvier + 3 jours ça
nous amène au 3 février 2020 par contre
si je fais mince je rajoute un mois
j'obtiens une valeurs manquantes
tout simplement parce que ça voudrait
quand on fait l'opération de base avec
un plus ça rajoute un mois aux mois en
cours et donc du coup j'obtiendrai une
date qui serait le 31 février 2020 et
c'est une date qui n'existe pas et donc
du coup ce que l'on va faire c'est on va
utiliser un autre opérateur qui fait
pour lequel plus calendaire qui est
pourcentage m plus
ce pourcentage est vous avez aussi
l'équivalent pourcentage m - pourcentage
l'intérêt c'est que lui va prendre en
compte le fait que tous et non pas la
même durée et donc par exemple lorsque
je décide de rajouter un mois au 31
janvier 2020 comme le 31 février
n'existe pas il va revenir sur la
première date qui est valide et donc du
coup on va avoir le 29 février 2020
quelque chose de cohérent donc ici pour
garder d'être valide ces pourcentages m
+ pourcentage d'accord et en faisant ça
j'ai fait mon repos d'agent d'entretien
je peux donc re calcul et ma durée
d'observation et je peux même le mettre
dans le même mieux tu es pour gagner en
temps et donc si je regarde maintenant
enfants durée observation est en fait un
seul bris
voyez je n'ai plus de valeurs minimum
donc les onze observations qui était
problématique
elles ont été corrigés alors première
étape nous avons pu calculer la durée
d'observation ce qui va être maintenant
important pour l'analyse c'est de
regarder du coulage au décès donc l'âge
au décès est stocké dans la variable h
décès et si je regarde rapidement
comment s est variable
voyez quand il ya des âges au décès j'ai
des valeurs entière si je fais un
tableau de fréquences je vais avoir zéro
mois un mois deux mois trois moins
quatre mois cinq mois simon autrement
dit la manière dont l'âge au décès a été
collecté s'étant mois révolus
les 62 enfants qui sont décédés à 0 mois
révolus son nom décédée entre 0 et 1
mois exact les cinq enfants qui sont
décédés à un mois révolus sont décédés
entre un mois et deux mois exact puisque
l'on n'a plus la partie décimales on a
vu juste avant les durée d'observation
compte est calculée avec timeline on les
parties décimales donc ce sont donc des
durée d'observation en moi exact ici
l'âge au décès est en mois révolus pour
pouvoir faire l'analyse parce qu'on va
devoir combiner les deux temporalités à
un moment donné on va devoir du coup
décidé si on fait une analyse en moi
exact ou en mois révolus
nous avons trois possibilités la
première possibilité
c'est de dire qu'on va garder les durée
d'observation en mois révolus et pour ça
il suffit de garder la partie entière
des durée d'observation et ça se fait
tout simplement avec la fonction prink
il est important de ne pas confondre la
fonction trunk et la fonction want one
hand c'est une fonction pour arrondir
mais qui a arrondi à l'entier le plus
proche alors que trunk arrondi à
l'entier le plus proche de zéro
autrement dit pour des chiffres positifs
prend lanthier qui est situé en dessous
je vous montre un exemple si je fais le
round de 11.8 je vais obtenir 12
si je fais jnk de 11.8 j'obtiendrai 11
donc une première possibilité c'est
d'appliquer trunk sur la variable durée
d'observation pour obtenir une durée
d'observation en mois révolus et nous
ferions alors tout l'analysant mois
révolus
une autre possibilité est de considérer
qu'un âge au décès de trois mois révolus
correspond en moyenne à 3,5 mois exact
puisque les enfants qui ont décédé à
trois mois révolus ont décédé entre 3 et
4 mois exact donc en moyenne à 3 5 mois
exact c'est une première possibilité on
fait une petite correction qui est la
même sur tout le monde mais qui permet
de revenir à quelque chose qui est en
tout cas un petit peu mieux caler enfin
une dernière possibilité et c'est celle
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
bah pour voir comment ça se réalise
c'est de faire une application sur l'âge
au décès donc le principe ici on sait on
incertitudes sur l'âge au dessert on
sait qu'il ya un âge à trois mois
révolus
c'est entre trois et quatre mois
est ce que l'on va pouvoir faire ces
montants de rajouter de manière
aléatoire
une partie des six malausain jeux
d'essai l'idée l'idée qu'on va faire
dans ces cas là voilà c'est du coup de
partir sur une distribution uniforme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
distribution uniforme ça consiste à
considérer que au sein d'un même mois
dont entre autres entre 4 mois et 5 mois
exactes des décès sont répartis de
manière à peu près uniforme entre 4 et 5
ce qui voudrait dire en fait faire une
approximation l'inr donc ce que l'on
souhaite obtenir c'est un nombre
aléatoire compris entre 0 et la fonction
qui permet de faire ça dans rc la
fonction r une niche alors si je fais
air unif 1
ça va me sortir un nombre aléatoire
entre 0 et 1 selon la distribution
uniforme
si je regarde l'aide air unif je peux
indiquer n en premier lieu c'est le
nombre d'observations je vais avoir puis
le entre quelle valeur et quelles
valeurs doivent être prises nombres
aléatoires
si je fais air unif disent ça va me
sortir dit nombres aléatoires compris
entre 0 et 1 si je fais mine égal 0 max
et il ya le 257 ça va me sortir dit
nombre prix aléatoirement entre 0 et 2
157 ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous
avez les distribuer sur la plupart des
distributions statistiques
dans air par exemple vous avez aussi air
norme c'est pour la distribution normale
qui ça vous intéresse et donc on peut
générer des nombres aléatoires qui
suivent une distribution normale avec
air normes
si je fais air normes disent ça va me
générés 10 nombre aléatoire qui suivent
une loi normale de moyenne 0 et d'écart
type 1 et vous pouvez paramétrer ses
deux éléments là vous avez aussi la
fonction et repas sont inquiets la
distribution de poissons et là je peux
sortir des nombres si je fais r poisse
dit ça va me sortir dit non à il faut
indiquer un lambda
qui 3 et donc on va avoir dix nombre
entier qui sur une loi de poissons de
moyenne
3 donc vous avez toutes ces
fonctionnalités ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est du coup de sortir un
nombre aléatoire de manier selon la
distribution uniforme entre 0 et 1 donc
air unif la petite astuce c'est que bon
on va les gérer de manière totalement
aléatoire et on va juste les rajouter à
tous les âges au décès autrement dit ce
que je vais faire je vais prendre mon
fichier enfants newton pour calculer une
nouvelle variable et je vais calculer un
âge au décès imputés qui sera tout
simplement l'âge au décès plus un nombre
aléatoire compris entre 0 et mais ce que
je vais faire c'est pour chacune de mes
lit je vais prendre un nombre aléatoire
différents donc là pour faire le calcul
il me faut un nombre de valeurs qui est
égal au nombre de lignes dans le tableau
et donc que je peux avoir directement
dans le mythe est avec elle si je
regarde maintenant le fichier enfants
voilà vous voyez à chaque fois je vais
avoir des âges au décès sur lesquels on
a rajouté une petite partie aléatoire
si je regarde la moyenne si je fais ce
mari deux âges
deux enfants et bien l'âge moyen au
décès que nous avions était de 6,2 et
l'âge moyen au décès imputés et de 6,7
soit 6,2 +0 5
et c'est normal puisque en utilisant une
une distribution uniforme
on a ajouté des noms pris au hasard
entre 0 et 1 mais du coup de manière
aléatoire de manière uniforme
il avait une valeur de 0 5 et donc du
coup on a on a corrigé notre âge de
cette manière reste maintenant que nous
avons l'âge au décès
plus nous avons notre ajournée au décès
notre durée de survie notre durée
d'observation il nous faut calculer les
variables de survie alors dont r
l'analyse de survie se fait avec un
package en particulier qui le package
survival
donc on va tout de suite le mettre en
mémoire c'est vraiment le package de
référence pour l'analyse de survie est
un objet de survie ou une variable de
survie elle se définit avec la fonction
servent et si on regarde l'aide de la
fonction servent
on va nous expliquer comment sont
définis un objet de survie par défaut
dans le cas le plus simple c'est à dire
on a uniquement une censure à droite
c'est celui qu'on va avoir
il nous faut deux informations pour les
données s'en sort et à droite
il nous faut une durée et une variable
event qui vaut tout files ou 0 au live
one dead ou 1 2 avec de vovo dead nous
dans le cas présent on va créer une
variable 0 est en vie un est décédé donc
1 a connu l'événement
c'est un peu comme dans la régression
logistique
qui est on va avoir une variable de
temps mais qui vaut deux choses
différentes
si on est décédé si on a vécu
l'événement d' analyse cette variable
temps devra valoir la durée à laquelle
on a vécu l'événement si par contre
l'individu n'a pas vécu l'événement sert
qu'il est toujours vivant à la fin de
l'observation du coup la variable temps
sera la durée d'observation et à
laquelle du coup on va censurer à droite
puisque on ne sait plus ce qui se passe
après donc il nous faut déjà une
variable event à cette variable bowie si
on a survécu 06 non or dans le cas
présent si je regarde me variable survie
elle vaut ainsi l'enfant a survécu est
toujours en vie zéro sinon en fait nous
ce qu'il nous faut c'est ainsi l'enfant
décédé zéro s'il est toujours en vie
dont du coup on va créer une variable
event qu'yvette ou décès qui est juste
linverse de notre de notre variable
survie donc je re fond nude ce décès
c'est égal et comme j'ai pas de valeurs
manquantes angers pas m'en occuper
ça c'est pratique donc if hausse
donc si jamais survie égal zéro alors ça
vaut 1
sinon ça vaut zéro et puis ton j'y suis
il en profite pour documenter donc cette
variable la baisse donc décès est
décédée cette vallée où la berce décès
ses envies égal zéro décédé également
et puis il va nous falloir aussi une
variable de temps et on l'a vu cette
variable de temps c'est si l'enfant est
décédé c'est l'âge au décès si l'enfant
est en vie à ce moment là
c'est la durée d'observation et donc je
vais créer mon objet times mais pas je
vais faire un fps donc survie égal zéro
donc là c'est qu'ils en font des cd on
va prendre l'âge au décès imputés
sinon on va prendre durée observation
est ce que j'ai bien écrit h décès
imputés petites fautes de frappe et donc
si on regarde maintenant d'autres objets
enfants j'ai à la fin une variable décès
qui vaut un en cas de décès zéro sinon
est une variable de temps qui est soit
l'âge au décès en cas d'essai sur la
durée d'observation en cas de survie
alors une petite question qui est posée
dans le chat a
du live c'est pouvez-vous revenir sur
l'imputation des âges au décès je
reviens sur ce code de l'âge au décès
d'accord ici ce que je fais je rajoute à
la variable hd c'est une valeur
aléatoire compris entre 0 et 1 qui dit
ce qui suit une distribution uniforme
c'est à dire que toutes les valeurs
entre 0 et ont vraiment la même
probabilité d'être sélectionné et donc
en moyenne ça sera 0,5 mais on voit là
c'est juste
et ont la même chance d'être tiré au
sort et ce que je fais donc mon annif me
permet si je fais un bon anniv 1
je vais tirer au sort une de ses valeurs
de manière aléatoire
si je fais roenick disent je vais avoir
dit valeur au sort là ce qui se passe
c'est que dans mon fichier en font les
bains j'ai un vecteur hd c'est donc
c'est une variable qui à 1584 valeur
d'accord donc pour faire un calcul entre
deux vecteurs j'additionne de vecteurs
de même longueur d'onde je vais prendre
un vecteur hd c'est qu' à 1584 valeur
dont des valeurs manquantes
est ce que je vais faire je vais généré
1584 valeur aléatoire selon une
distribution uniforme et pour indiquer
ce nombre 1584 c'est à dire le nombre de
ligne 1 qui lie à d'enfants je peux
directement comme je suis dans un goûter
était que je suis dans des plats hier
utiliser la fonction n et n
à l'intérieur des new tate à l'intérieur
de sunrise à l'intérieur des fonctions
de deep lier c'est un raccourci pour le
nombre de lignes dont grenier m la haine
vos 1584 donc ça génère 1584 valeur
aléatoire qui sont rajoutés du coup hd
c'est ce qui est intéressant ici c'est
que sais je vous montre vous voyez les
âges au décès qu'on a dans notre base
pardon ils sont là et à chaque page
décès imputés je vais aller voir les
adjots des seuils sont ici d'accord 00
dans un premier temps puis après on a un
deux trois quatre cinq et mots ce que
j'ai fait c'est j'ai simplement ajouter
une partie décimales complètement
aléatoire par contre la partie entière
est bien respectée
cet enfant est décédé ses premiers
enfants là sont décidés entre à trois
mois révolus c'est donc qu'ils sont
décédés entre 3 et 4 mois exacte et j'ai
juste rajouter à une partie aléatoire
l'intérêt c'est l'imputation s'est du
coup de faire un peu un lissage sur mes
données
parce que si jamais j'avais
si jamais on revenait en mois révolus
j'aurais fait juste un truck
ou alors j'aurais pu vous l'avez dit
rajouter juste 0,5 mais ça en fait
permettre de points au même endroit et
là en fait ce que je cherchais juste à
glisser légèrement mais donner encore
une fois les plusieurs approches sont
possibles
l'autre manière ça aurait été d'utiliser
et pour vous montrer donc ça c'est la
durée d'observation exact d'accord et
j'aurais pu calculer une durée
d'observation au mois révolus en faisant
simplement jean luc le dur et
observations
alors j'ai pigé vous qu'est ce qu'on me
semble qu'on va faire la comparaison des
deux modèles sur les variables de survie
la fonction time
elle est l'un des jeux vous faire un
time révolue donc si j'étais fait
l'analyse en noir évoluent dans ce cas
là j'aurais pris l'âge au décès et la
durée d'observation en mois révolus
alors avant de se lancer dans l'analyse
de survie vous le savez une grosse
partie du travail c'est toujours la
partie bar codage nous allons rapidement
nous occuper des variables explicatives
que l'on veut inclure dans le modèle
[Applaudissements]
donc déjà ce qui va nous falloir c'est
pouvoir récupérer un certain nombre de
variables qui sont dans le fichier femme
ou dans le fichier aménage et déjà pour
récupérer les variables du fichier
ménages il faut qu'on récupère
l'identifiant du ménage que nous n'avons
pas dans le fichier enfants je vous
ramène comment elle fichiers en font le
fichier enfants ici n'a pas
l'identifiant du ménage il a un idée
femmes par contre on a identifié du
ménage dans
dans le fichier femmes ce que je vais
faire je pars toujours de mon fichier
enfants d'accord on va faire un live de
john et qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
partir du fichier femme et je vais faire
select pour choisir uniquement les
variables d'intérêt que je veux rajouter
dans mon fichier enfants donc là pour le
coup il me faut y des femmes pour la
jointure je vais récupérer y déménage on
va prendre le milieu de résidence le
niveau d'éducation
d'accord je veux la date de naissance de
la mère sauf que dans le fichier femmes
la date de naissance de la mère
s'appelle date naissance et dans
fichiers enfants jets d'eau des jeunes
variable d'être naissance qui est la
naissance de l'enfant
donc pour éviter qu'on s'y mélangent je
vais prendre donc la date de naissance
de la mère sauf que je vais la renommée
la volée ce qu'on peut faire
je vais appeler sa date de naissance mr
donc quand vous en ça quand je fais mon
select je vais renommée à la volée date
naissance en tête naissance merde en
fichiers femme avant de faire mon lev
taurine et puis enfin il nous faudra le
nombre d'enfants idéal
ça fait beaucoup de choses j'aime mettre
sur plusieurs lignes
hop là pour ce soit plus facile à lire
donc l'âge et les variables du fichier
femmes et et on va dire bye égale y des
femmes et alors il ya une fois quelque
part et c'est ici milieu donc si je
prends maintenant mon fichier enfants
voyez j'ai tout un tas de nouvelles
variables qui sont maintenant à ma
disposition
et puis il ya donc des et maintenant je
dispose d'un identifiant ménages qui va
me permettre de pouvoir récupérer des
variables du fichier ménages ont refait
la même chose on va faire donc enfants
je pars deux enfants left john
donc là je pars du fichier ménages
select donc on veut la variable qui
déménagent parce que c'est sur cette
variable
on va pouvoir maintenant faire la fusion
est il ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
structure démographique du ménage
structure et richesses simplement on va
dire bye égale y déménage pour indiquer
la variable de fusion si je fais enfants
j'ai bien le résultat voulu ôter
nouvelles variables et je pourrais
éventuellement gagner en syntaxe en
faisant tout une seule fois alors
attention quelque chose d'important
c'est quand vous faites des fusions
n'exécutait pas deux fois le code si je
ré exécutait ceci on aurait quelques
surprises
pourquoi
parce que quand on fusionne des
variables qui ont déjà été rajoutés
sacré des doublons vous avez voyez un
dat naissance mer pour les x et un
nombre au fonds mondial point x et des
variables pour les grecs un sas ailier
parce qu'on a déjà fait la fusion
si jamais on a fait elle est un peu des
bêtises on sait plus trop où en est on
appuie affiché très propre
l'intérêt c'est qu'on va pouvoir tour
exécuté depuis le début et là je vais
cliquez sur sources pour tour exécuté et
vérifier que j'ai bien maintenant un
fichier propre sang variable doublonner
alors nous avons un certain nombre de
variables que l'on veut utiliser
notamment baptisé le sexe de l'enfant
le niveau de richesse vous voyez quand
le mont les variables dalles sont codées
sous la forme de vecteurs labellisés
sauf que pour un modèle multivariée les
variables catégorielles vont devoir être
codé sous forme de facteurs donc je vais
commencer à faire un peu de
transformations et transformer ces
variables en facteurs et ça ça se fait
tout simplement être la fonction tout
factor de la belle si je fais sexe égal
tout facteur de sexe et richesses
ingall tout factor de richesse
si l'on regarde le fichier enfants et le
sexe c'est maintenant un facteur qui a
été facilement recoder si je regardais
la forme que ça on peut faire enfants
look fort donc ça c'est louis et les
crochets c'est celle qui sont encore des
vecteurs labellisé le niveau de vie mais
l'écho des entrées pauvres pour moyens
riche très riche c'est complètement
cohérente en terme d'ordre et la g
masculin féminin dans les modalités pour
les enfants la question qui peut se
poser c'est qu'est-ce que je fais de la
variable structure faisons un petit
tableau de fréquences ce qu'on voit
c'est que la modalité à d'adultes dans
le ménage et pas du tout représentés et
c'est normal parce qu'un ménage où il
n'ya pas d'adultes s'aménage où il n'ya
pas de mer donc c'est un ménage où il
n'y a pas d'enfant
donc ce que l'on va vouloir faire pour
la suite
d'accord c'est de supprimer on va
vouloir ne pas garder pas d'adultes et
on va voir que drop que tout factor nous
propose une fonction une option en six
volets toutes les options qui est dans
tous facteurs on peut utiliser du coup
une option qui est drop music label ce
pour que quand on convertissent les
étiquettes qui ne sont pas observées
dans les valeurs ne soit pas garder ou
alors on pourrait tirer la fonction etc
c'était drop de foire 4 pour supprimer
les valeurs qui ne qui ne sont plus en
place donc ce que je vais faire pour la
variable structure rien donc ça va être
tout factor
deux structures sur lequel on va ajouter
un fct drop pour supprimer la modalité
qui n'est pas utilisé et puis ce que je
veux faire je voudrais mettre finalement
commodité de référence pour mon de la
suite de mon modèle la modalité deux
adultes de sexe opposé qui est la
modalité la plus représentée 505 c'est
un ménage où il ya au moins deux adultes
de sexe opposé
c'est grosso modo le ménage nucléaire
donc pour mettre ça en premier on va
pouvoir utiliser fct oui leuwers qui
permet d'indiquer une modalité a placé
en premier et donc si je regarde
maintenant look fort et puis on va
mettre directement est et lavable
structure elle est du coup devenue un
facteur avec 5 modalités vous voyez que
la modalité pas d'adulte a disparu et
que deux adultes de sexe opposé est
devenue la première modalités tout ça
c'est des choses qu'on a déjà vu ça fait
partie de choses qu'on a pu avoir
maintenant on va vouloir s'occuper de la
variable niveau d'éducation
alors comment elle s'appelle l'éducation
c'est la variable
on sait pas et duke
si donc on est une variable éducation
avec aucun primaire secondaire supérieur
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
transformer ça en un facteur mais on va
ensuite ici de fusionner supérieure avec
secondaire donc on va prendre et duke
[Musique]
donc c'est tout facteur de l'educ
et f c'était oui code qui permet de re
coded est donc fct recode pour revoir
son comment ça se présente
c'est sous la forme nouvelle valeur
égale ans et une valeur donc là ce que
je vais dire c'est je vais recoder
supérieur en secondaire ou jamais appelé
ça secondaire sup est dedans je vais y
mettre
[Musique]
je crois que je peux donner deux valeurs
directement on va y mettre dedans
secondaire on va émettre supérieur
et ben non ça marche pas comme ça donc
la bonne syntaxe
je voulais tester s'il y avait un
raccourci normalement c'est celle ci et
si on regarde enfants y duc et qu'on
fait à votre fréquence donc là
maintenant c'est devenu un facteur et on
a bien regroupés ensemble les deux
modalités secondaires et supérieurs qui
sont devenues secondaires issues
alors on y est presque
ce qu'on voudrait maintenant c'est
pouvoir calculer l'âge de la mère à la
naissance de l'enfant
donc pour ça ce qu'on voit c'est que
dans le fichier en fond on à la date de
naissance de l'enfant et la date de
naissance de la mer et donc si on est
malin on a vu que ça ça pouvait du coup
[Musique]
l'âge de la mère à la naissance
d'accord et bien c'est tout simplement
intervalles et ilife
donc c'est l'intervalle entre dattes
naissance mer et date naissance
[Musique]
et on applique dessus d'un globe sur ce
résultat-là unit égal hier puisqu'on va
calculer cette fois-ci l'âge de la mère
en année alors content parce que j'ai
déjà fait mon tout factor 2011
ah oui on a déjà reconnaît donc du coup
il en est pas alors ce qu'on va faire le
tour faire depuis le début que je fais
une variable et du neuf plutôt que
d'avoir créé donc nous avons maintenant
éduque 2 qui est ma version recoder du
niveau d'éducation et là vous avez l'âge
de la mère à la naissance en année ce
qu'on va faire c'est que si ces
pratiques d'avoir l'âge de la mère à la
naissance en année on va le on va le
garder plutôt en différents sous-groupes
1 pour la partie analytique et donc du
coup je vais recoder ma variable âge en
plusieurs catégories pour ça à dean et
je vais chercher les adin de
questionnaires et nous avons numérique
ouvrage dividing ce qui nous permet de
charger la petite application shiny la
petite interface c'est dans le fichier
enfants que je veux recoder la variable
h mais renaissance et je vais créer du
coup de variables que je vais appeler
groupe h mais renaissance pour dire que
ça va des classes d'âge je vais charger
la partie découpage hommage alors on
voit ici c'est derrick qui viennent
d'une de données ouest africaine donc on
a une majorité des naissances qu'ont
lieu
voyez l'âge - et là je me le médian à la
naissance et 25 ans et c'est assez
précoce ce qui va nous intéresser c'est
de se dire voilà il ya une période forte
fécondité qui sont les 20 30 29
les 20 30 ans exacte est on va
s'intéresser qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsque les mères sont vraiment jeune
moins de 20 ans ou lorsqu'elles ont
dépassé 30 ans donc je vais juste coupé
en trois groupes
mais donc j'ai découpé en
donc je veux couper à 20 et à 30 ans
j'inclus les valeurs extrêmes mais
intervalle vont être fermés à droite
alors voyons voir ce que ça donne comme
résultat
donc j'ai quelque chose qui va jusqu'à
20 ans puis inclut donc en fait c'est
sur le découpage fermé à droite qu'il
faut peut-être que j'inverse voilà je
vais jusqu'à maintenant inclus puis de
20 jusqu'à 30 puis de 30 à 48
ce qu'on peut faire c'est plutôt pour
pas à faire à pas et donc je vais
cliquez sur ce qu'on peut faire c'est au
lieu d'avoir des breaks c'est ici qu'ils
sont avec les valeurs observées
je vais rajouter 2 - 1 finit à l'infini
c'est une manière un petit peu différent
de présenter les choses mais ca en
compromis ans et tout ce qui avant 20
ans tout ce qui est après et je clique
sur que des résultats donc si je clique
sur donne ça va me copier le code ici
le paramètre dis-je la blonde est pas
vraiment besoin
donc si on fait ça ça ne crée bien mais
trois groupes
et puisqu'on va vouloir faire c'est
renommée les trois modalités
on peut le faire comme on l'avait fait
juste avant avec fc terrible cody et si
on est un peu feignant on peut passer
par li wenhui coding dans l'ead in de
questionnaires donc c'est la variable
groupe h mais renaissance deux enfants
ça va rester la même variable donc je
garde le même nom on va passer par la
cité recode c'est juste qu'on va
présenter sa com 19 ans au moins 20 29
ans 30 ans ou plus donne
vous voyez ça va simplement me copier
coller l'information et on veut on peut
le présenter un tout petit peu
différemment juste présenter la syntaxe
ce que je fais là c'est juste de la mise
en forme pour avoir quelque chose de
plus facile à lire
rien de plus donc je prends en compte
mais rage naissance et j'ai moins de 7
et recon et en cliquant sur sousse 1
j'aurais exécute l'ensemble des éléments
reste maintenant la varia un peu plus
compliqué a calculé un mec je vous ai
mis parce que c'est un bonne un bon
élément d'exercice il s'agit de savoir
si ce qu'on veut c'est une variable qui
nous dit voilà une mère une femme
considère que le nombre idéal d'enfants
et trois cirques quatrième enfant donc
du coup leur en fait c'est ce que le
rang de naissance d'un enfant est situé
après ce nombre idéal d'enfants en
disant que peut-être ça ainsi le rang
des sens est supérieur aux idées halde
enfants
[Musique]
ça serait pas forcément voilà ça serait
pas forcément le bon pour calculer le
rang de naissance
il nous faut utiliser du coup la
fonction want qu on avait déjà abordé un
petit peu donc pouvoir c'est une
fonction qui calcule terran donc je vais
essayer de vous montrer un exemple
voilà vous avez ici on va prendre avec
des
voilà je vais vous prendre ce vecteur là
donc
supposons ici vous avez un vecteur
d'accord x qui vaut 3 1 4 1 5 9 2 6 5 3
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y avait peu de
doublons 1 3
il a deux fois le chiffre 3 il ya deux
fois le chiffre 5
si je fais le rang de mes différentes
valeurs pour comprendre ce que fait rend
ça me dit que trois c'est la quatrième
mise à l'heure en fait les 3 et 2 3
correspondent à la 4ème et la 5ème
valeur les deux un correspondant la
première et la deuxième valeur par
défaut ce que fait la fonction ranque
elle calcule un rang du coût moyen c'est
à dire que les 2 1
ici sont tous les deux les sons la
première et la deuxième valeur du
vecteur donc du coup ils leur attribuent
le rendent un ennemi vous avez aussi la
possibilité d'utiliser plusieurs
manières pour gérer les doublons et
trahissent méthode égale first ce que ça
fait ça nous dit ce chiffre-là c'est la
première valeur du vecteur le deuxième 1
sera conservée quelle est ma deuxième
valeur du vecteur donc c'est dans le lot
de curan et vecteur puis la troisième
valeur du vecteur c'est du coup ce
chiffre de qu'on trouve là est la
quatrième valeur c'est ce 3 et la
cinquième valeur c'est ce trois là une
autre manière de le faire c'est
d'utiliser mine alors ça consiste à dire
que les deux seins sont tous les deux
premiers ils sont premiers ex-aequo
puis le chiffre 2 cayla lui les 3e et
puis les trois là ils sont quatrièmes
ex-aequo il n'y a pas de cinquième et en
sixième nous aurons du coup ce 4 et
enfin l'autre possibilité c'est de faire
mac c'est à dire que du coup on prend
leur maximum pour chacun d'eux considère
que les deux premiers y sont les 2 1
ce
1la et sera là sont tous les deux en
deuxième position il n'y a pas deux
premiers donc voilà il faut bien
comprendre qu'on a plusieurs manières de
gérer les duplicatas lorsqu'on calcule
les rangs la question c'est quelle va
être la bonne manière de faire pour nous
nous en l'occurrence et si jamais il
devait y avoir des jumeaux il y avait
deux enfants catelli nés le même jour
comme la sq on s'intéresse à voir c'est
à comparer le rang de naissance par
rapport au nombre idéal d'enfants donc
si jamais on avait deux jumeaux pas ça
ferait déjà deux enfants et qu'elle
avait dit que le rôle nombre idéal
c'était un on a dépassé ce nombre idéal
donc dans notre cas présent va calculer
le rang avec l'option max mais vraiment
retenez bien que faut bien réfléchir
preuve cas par cas et qu'est ce que l'on
fait dans son domaine pour savoir quelle
est la bonne manière de calculer le rend
en tout cas pour les pour les doublons
mais dans notre cas ce qui va nous être
utile du coup c'est le rang est le truc
c'est qu'on va calculer laurent
séparément c'est au sein de chat pour
une même mère c'est de rendre naissance
pour une même mère donc ici on va
prendre le fichier enfants on va trier
le fichier enfants par mr donc avec qui
des femmes puis partent à de naissance
alors puis je vais faire un groupe bail
et je vais faire le calcul séparément
pour chaque femme dont group buy in des
femmes et là je vais faire mon minou
tate rang égal branques date de
naissance alors j'aurais pu ne pas ne
pas trier 1 puisque leur en aurait
fonctionné ici mais ce qu'il faut c'est
le groupe by paris des femmes pour que
quel que soit bien faite vers par mer en
indiquant ties méthode égal max et enfin
je calcule emma variable qui est rang
après idéal et je vais ça va être un kif
health
si mon rang est supérieur au nombre
d'enfants idéal
alors la question c'est comment est
stockée la variable nber en fond idéale
donc c'est un nom ok donc est ce que si
j'aimais ses supérieurs alors rang après
idéal bowie sinon ça vaut nous faisons
le test regardons fichiers enfants dont
il est bien calculé ma variable ici
alors je vous montre ça un peu pour
l'exemple et histoire de calculer un cas
un peu compliqué d'accord et d'ailleurs
là on a justement un cas de figure pour
les lignes 2 et 3 1 d'une décence
jumelles r on a deux enfants qui sont
nés à la même date c'est pour la mer 2
et donc du coup ils ont tous les deux
été marquée comme oran 2 et comme leur
le nombre idéal d'enfants pour cette
femme là c'est 2 1
du coup les deux ont été comptés comme
rang après idéal
là la variable que je viens de faire ces
deux variables on a fait un peu
rapidement pour vous montrer un exemple
de calcul compliqué mais c'est pas une
variable tout à fait correct pour deux
raisons d'une part le fichier enfants ne
contient que les naissances il ya moins
de cinq ans et donc du coup on ne sait
pas ici à ce stade si cette femme-là eu
des enfants plus âgés qui sont encore en
vie aujourd'hui
donc là le nombre d'enfants est pas tout
à fait correct parce qu'il nous manque
les premières naissances on aurait une
table enfants qui auraient été tous
l'histoire génésique des femmes et non
pas les chars génésique des cinq
dernières années mais l'histoire
génétique complète des femmes
là on aurait eu un calcul corps était
plus juste l'autre élément en toute
rigueur il faudra aussi tenir compte des
décès parce que si jamais il y a des
grands frères et grandes soeurs qui sont
décédés avant cette grossesse là à ce
moment là il faudrait tenir compte
qu'ils ne sont plus présents au moment
de la grossesse et que du coup on n'a
pas dépassé le nombre idéal de l'enfant
donc là c'est juste pour vous faire un
exemple un peu concrets de
comment on peut commencer à calculer des
variables plus complexe mais voyez que
même là il nous manque certaines
informations pour être totalement
rigoureux et puis dernier élément ça on
va le transformer en factor facteurs et
donc du coup je vais mettre non en
premier donc level égal non oui ça me
permet de ce que là j'écris une variable
textuelle et je transforme ici en
facteurs maintenant nous avons préparé
toutes nos variable nous allons enfin
pouvoir nous attaquer à l'analyse de
survie proprement dite et en premier
lieu aux calculs de la courbe de kaplan
meier
[Musique]
donc la courbe de kepler meilleur c'est
la manière de représenter de représenter
notre objet de survie est donc là on est
vraiment à statistiques purement
descriptive à cette étape là donc on l'a
vu tout début on a chargé en mémoire le
paquet survival la courbe de kaplan
meier se calcule avec la fonction sur
vite on va voir dans un premier temps
cette coupe de kaplan meier global dont
je vais l'appeler keim global donc je
vais appeler sauve fit et je voulais dit
mon objet de survie se définit avec la
fonction servent à laquelle on doit
passer le temps puis l'événement dont g
nous on avait créé une variable time est
une variable décès et pour le moment on
veut juste la décret dont je vais faire
tilt d'1 donc c est on en train de
décrire une sur deux modèles donc c'est
la courbe de survie en fonction de rien
d'autre
donc juste en fait ça et on va indiquer
le jeu de données data etc à l'enfant
alors si j'affiche directement ma courbe
de kaplan meier 1
j'obtiens un résumé donc nous avons 1584
observations avec 142 événements alors
j'ai pas le médiane parce qu'en fait
dans les données qu'on observe on
n'atteint pas les 50% de d'événements
vécus et fort heureusement va se réduire
ce qui nous intéresse avec de pouvoir
représenter tout ça d'un point de vue
graphique et pour ça on va avoir recours
à la fonction le package sauf marine us
fournie
on pour faire des représenter des objets
de survie avec gégé pelote de klein
bruits soeur myners et je vais pouvoir
du coup utiliser gg surv pelote et du
passé ma courbe de kaplan meier donc là
vous voyez j'ai un premier graphique on
va le on va zoomer donc ça nous indique
pour chaque pas de temps si le
pourcentage de personnes qui sont
toujours en vie on en voyait on démarre
à cent pour cent
et puis ça va diminuer progressivement
et laraque est donné qu'on a on est à
peu près à 80
1 5 90% de survie passé passé passé 60
mois au niveau de cinq ans là on va
essayer d'améliorer un petit peu notre
graphique est plutôt que de représenter
le pourcentage de gens qui sont toujours
en vie on pourrait représenter le
pourcentage de gens qui ont vécu
l'événement pour ça je vais reprendre la
fonction surf pelote et je vais rajouter
fun égale event donc la différence est
que cette fois ci on représente le
pourcentage cumulé de ce qu'ils ont vécu
l'événement c'est à dire ici à 30 mois
ils sont à peu près 10 % de
l'échantillon un cd données qui sont
anciennes et dont on voit une mortalité
infantile élevé 10% échantillon est
décédé
donc c'est bien toujours que c'est dieu
sait et cd cd pourcentage cumulé
d'événements je peux améliorer le
graphique en rajoutant aussi ce qu'on
appelle la tête des risques vous voulez
ce que tu es bon show c'est de savoir
finalement il ya combien d'observation à
chaque étape puisque on a un certain
nombre de personnes et d'enfants qui
sortent de l'observation au fur et à
mesure on voit un à l'étape 20 - il ya
neuf cent trente quatre enfants qui sont
observés jusqu'à ce point là on a en
fait personne observé jusqu'à 60 et à 50
mois ils sont plus que deux soins
observer ce qui fait que le début de la
courbe de survie étaient 6000 manière
assez fine mais elle est beaucoup plus
incertaine sur la suite d'ailleurs où
vous voyez là par défaut vous avez les
intervalles de confiance qui vous sont
représentés
qui sont représentés en rose clair ce
qu'on peut aussi améliorer légèrement la
courbe c'est d'avoir ici non pas du
point 0,5 ou du point 10 mai d'avoir des
pourcentages ce qui peut là aussi se
modifier avec surf à points ce qui est
égal arrivés vers cents 1 pour
représenter plutôt des pur sang ou de
survie ici alors il n'y a plus d'options
qui sont possibles sur le graphique on
peut toujours aller voir gg surf pelote
si on veut plus d'informations sur les
options disponibles ainsi que la
documentation deux soeurs myners qui
montrera tout ce qui peut être fait
parce qu'on peut combiner pas mal de
choses et notamment
on peut alors ce qu'il serait peut-être
pas mal
ou est-ce qu'on indique les points de
censure on peut changer des couleurs on
peut changer un salon de jeu de donner à
ce qui va m'intéresser
j'aimerais bien c'est que comme on
travaille en moi sur le graphique plutôt
d'avoir 10 20 30 40 50 60 je préférerais
avoir 12 24 36 ans correspond plutôt à
qui correspondent à des années entières
ce qui nous permet d'y voir un d'y voir
un petit peu mieux et je ne me souviens
plus où ça ça se modifier mais si on va
chercher groupe haïti blind faith and
company gg thème faveur guns 'n sincère
ni aux pelotes wec tampa voilà ici on
voit qu'il ya un paramètre brighton bail
qui permet d'indiquer comment est-ce
qu'on découpe donc je suppose que si je
rajoute break sempai égal 12la j'aime
bien mon 12 24 36 48 de jeu coup j'ai de
12 mois 12 mois ce qui permet d'avoir
quelque chose de le plus cohérent
puisque ce sont des mois que ça permet
de voir en année vous voyez également un
petit effet ça c'est assez classique
voyez il ya une montée brusque d'un coup
à 12 24 36 et 48 alors c'est pas lié au
fait qu'il n'y a plus de décès aux âges
rond prince est pas que tout d'un coup
quand on a 12 mois ou 24 mois 36 mois
c'est juste que souvent et ça c'est un
problème de collecte d'informations
quand on demande aux personnes à quel
âge l'enfant est décédé on va facilement
répondre
il avait deux ans et l'enquêteur du
couvent a renseigné 24 mois plutôt que
d'essayer d'avoir plus spécifiquement si
c'était plutôt à 23 mois ou à 26 mois
donc ce qui fait qu'on a une sorte
d'attirance osages diront
là du coup à 12 mois à 24 36 à 48 et que
du coup il ya cet artefact d'une montée
d'un coup alors qu'en fait la montre et
devrait être plus progressive au cours
du temps alors maintenant que nous avons
une autre
notre courbe de survie donc là vous
voyez elle a été fait
n'oubliez pas cette version fait avec
avec nos données qu'on était imputèrent
donc on a légèrement glissé au cours du
temps si j'avais utilisé si j'avais
refait la même chose mais en utilisant
les données révolu en mois révolus donc
c'est à dire donc dans l'objet enfants
c'était le temps 7 5
on avait appelé times révolue si je vous
refais le graphique cette fois-ci non
pas avec notre réputation sur les mois
mais en utilisant du coup le temps
révolu et on va refaire le même
graphique
la petite différence c'est que du coup
notamment là on a beaucoup de choses qui
se passent alors d'une part tout le
point ont forcément lieu que sur les
mois donc on à cet effet en escalier
beaucoup plus marquée dans ce qui est
normal mais surtout cette montée d'un
coup à zéro et c'est pas qu'il ya 4 %
des enfants qui sont décédés le jour de
leur naissance ils sont destinés au
cours du premier mois mais comme là ils
ont tous marqué comme comme 0 ans
révolus on a cet effet-là d'envoyer la
différence entre l'auteur évolue il faut
avoir conscience que ce premier point là
ça veut pas dire à 0 que c'est qu'on
fait ici c'est entre 0 et 1 mois qui est
un petit décalage
et puis s'est défait en escalier que
l'on va gommer lorsque du coup on
repasse sur le graphique
que l'on a fait parce qu'on a rajouté en
fait un petit peu aléatoires en
déballant les en dépassant légèrement
les points donc la courbe de la courbe
est à peu près la même mais voyez cette
différence ici sur lausanne 0 1 nous qui
va être appelé par une droite linéaire
donc c'est l'effet qu'on a fait par
l'imputation ce qui est intéressant
c'est de pouvoir comparer à un moment
donné avait faire une analyse vivarié
donc ce qu'on veut ça serait pouvoir à
savoir est ce que les coupes du survie
sont différentes en fonction du sexe de
l'enfant
et ça ça peut se faire très simplement
c'est comme tout à l'heure on va en
faire du coût des cowboys de caplong
magnan pour deux sous groupes
donc ici je vais simplement rajouté sexe
et je vous fais les gg sauf pelote
on va reprendre ici nos options sauf que
je lui passe le cap lohmeier par sexe
je vous la met en grand et d'envoyer les
deux cours de survie pour les garçons et
pour les filles
là on a maintenant du coup de couleur
l'estrade sont indiquées et on voit du
coup une mortalité élevée chez les
jeunes garçons par rapport à la
mortalité observée chez les filles ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire éventuellement
c'est récupérer une paix va leur pour
avoir est-ce que c'est vraiment
significatif et on a normalement dans
les options béval égale chaud pour
rajouter sur graphique la mention de la
paix valeur donc la wii est un pays qui
est inférieur à 0,001 donc là on a très
clairement une élément différent si on
veut la retrouver on peut aussi
directement affiché un calme sexe alors
là c'est si j'affiche quand même sexe
dans la console
et si on les passe à sa mairie alors ça
me renvoie le détail et le pay valeur ou
est ce qu'on peut avoir sinon à oui
parlons c'est si on veut calculer la
paix va leur en fait la paix valeur elle
se calcule non pas avec surf fit mais
avec surf dif
c'est la même syntaxe sauf qu'au lieu
d'indiquer son co lieu d'indiquer sauf
fit vous avez appelé la fonction sauf
dif et la fonction se redisent vous
affiche du coup cette paix valeur
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que si
jamais on on prend ce qui si je
m'intéressais d'une part au sexe mais
aussi à l'âge de la mère qu'on appelait
gp âge mais renaissance supposons que je
fais un kaplan bailleur ou jamais deux
variables sexe et âge la mer qu'est ce
que j'obtiens
alors ça prend beaucoup de place mais ce
qui se passe c'est que si jamais vous
mettez deux variables dans dans votre
kaplan meier un ces variables là du coup
sont croisés entraîne donc c'est toutes
les combinaisons qui vont être faites
pour faire en fait les kaplan manière
dont on va croiser les deux variables
mais ça ne donne pas forcément l'effet
de l'âge et l'effet du sexe si on
voulait du coup avoir un modèle qui
prenne en compte tous les éléments pour
cela on aurait recours à un modèle de
comme ce donc le modèle de cox c'est le
modèle de survie il est basé sur série
en fait sur les courbes alors plus que
si physiquement ce qui modélise c'est
pas tant la courbe de survie mais que
les risques instantané à chaque tente et
oui une des hypothèses majeure du modèle
de cox c'est un lapereau la
proportionner des risques c'est-à-dire
qu'on suppose que si jamais les garçons
ont un risque deux fois plus élevé
le risque est toujours deux fois plus
élevé c'est-à-dire que le risque des
garçons seraient deux fois plus élevés
entre 0 et 12 mois et entre 12 mois et
24 mois c'est l'hypothèse de
proportionnalité des risques le money de
l'eau cox est vraiment facile à calculer
[Musique]
vous voyez comme toujours on passe
beaucoup plus de temps à préparer donné
qu'à faire le nez en tant que tel je
vais faire un tout premier modèle pour
lequel j'appelle la fonction cox ph
ce que l'on va faire on a indiqué le
modèle en tant que tel donc en fait
c'est on faisait comme pour la
régression logistique c'est un peu la
même idée sauf que notre variable
expliqué c'est un objet de survie donc
je définis comme time et d'essai
et là je vais pouvoir l'expliquer en
fonction de mes différentes variables le
sexe le milieu de résidence le niveau de
richesse du ménage la structure est qu
démographique du ménage notre variable
d'éducation que jarkko des dons qui
s'appellait duc 2 le alors comment j'ai
appelé le groupe da jamais année 106 ici
et puis notre fameux variable rang après
idéal
j'étais de me mettre sur deux lignes
pour ce soit plus visible et enfin on va
indiquer les données donc data égalant
fond et voilà j'ai calculé mon prêt de
cox la question c'est quelles vont être
les résultats alors je peux vous
l'affiché dans la console on vous allez
voir ça prend pas mal de places mais
vous avez donc le modèle de cox apparaît
ici tout simplement afficher dans la
console vous avez le coefficient du
modèle où les bêtas et vous avez sans
doute présenter les exponentielle des
coefficients parce que l'expérience et
les coefficients alors ce n'est pas des
ratios comme dans un modèle de
régression logistique ce sont des
hasards de rations mais ils sont voir
pour le coup interprétable vraiment
comme une multiplication autrement dit
là ce qu'on peut dire c'est que il est
de 0,44 pour les femmes par rapport aux
hommes ça veut dire que les femmes ont
65 soit deux tiers de chances en moins
d'être de décéder que les garçons en
vous rappelant à cette hypothèse que on
fait l'hypothèse que ce qu il fit ce
coefficient sur la rade ratio est la
même tout au long tout au long du temps
et enfin vous avez la paix valeur donc
là fortement
1 5-10 cette fois dix puissance moins 6
dont 1 p valeurs très petit pour le sexe
donc au sexe est très significatif
on va avoir une paix valeur ici à 0 2%
sur l'euro après idéal donc là cette
variable aussi un effet si on
représentait notre tableau de manière un
petit peu plus jolie et plus efficace et
bien on est maintenant habitué on a
d'une part library british mairie et on
va chercher aussi j'ai galilée devons
nous servir
donc vous devez vous souvenir de t-bills
relations je veux lui passé et mode 1
je vais rajouter exponentielle eagle
trop
donc là ça nous présente le tableau des
résultats donc si je vous le mets en
plus grand comme toujours c'est présenté
un peu plus proprement
donc on voit sexe de l'enfant 1,044 pour
les femmes p valeurs fortement élevé les
autres variables qui ont un effet
significatif via le milieu de résidence
les voyez il ya un petit souci en publié
de recoder le milieu de résidence en
facteurs donc on va les corriger notre
code ou est ce qu'on a fait leur codage
voilà le milieu n'a pas été recruté en
facteur il était comme variable
numérique donc milieu égal tout factor
de milieu et pour se faciliter la vie
on va tour exécuté
un envoyé l'intérêt de tout avoir en
syntaxe et que c'est facile de faire une
correction à un endroit et puis devrait
exécuter un ensemble de l'analyse donc
ça y est tout s'est remis en place
et du coup notre modèle devra se corrige
résidence est maintenant un facteur donc
on voit que la mortalité plus élevé au
milieu rural c'est significatif on est à
1 25% le niveau de vie n'a pas de valeur
globale alors ça peut être intéressant
d'avoir des paies valeur globale donc ce
qu'on va faire je vais je vais
sauvegarder mon tableau et puisque je
vais appeler je prends mon tableau on va
rajouter à d'un globule pis donc on
devrait avoir là on a des valeurs
globalement on a perdu les valeurs
individuelles donc on va garder les
valeurs individuelles donc pour si je
retourne sur l'aide de hatley ball pis
pour tibia gauche on s'équipe et gâteaux
donc si je rejoue maintenant sur mon
tableau on a du coup une valeur globale
pour les variables et les valeurs
individuelles on voit que là je ne joue
peu leur ans après idéal il est
faiblement significatif en global même
si le coefficient lui peut avoir un
effet donc là on aille du coup ici les
valeurs et je crois qu'une petite
nouveauté que vous avez pas encore
présente et je crois que maintenant il y
à agde signifie costa qui arrivent et
qui permet de rajouter des petites
étoiles au tableau alors c'est ça en
fait la retire lavalas colonnes paix
mais ça vous met les petites étoiles
mais on doit avoir aussi sur had
signifie qu'un star une option ait pays
on va désactiver donc on va faire ce qui
égale files ce qui nous permet en fait
de rajouter ces petites étoiles
voyez il ya des le package it is mairie
très actif et à des petites nouveautés
si on veut pouvoir regarder les
résultats à
du du modèle figurez vous que vous
pouvez maintenant sur un tableau que
vous avez calculé dangi tissu marie avec
taiwan faire pelote du tableau pour
obtenir ce graphique là et en fait ce
graphique là ça doit vous dire quelque
chose parce qu'en fait c'est basé sur le
fameux gg coeff modèle du package
égalise puisque thibaut jetty ce mal oui
j'ai galy partage du coup en commun le
package broum broum helpers pour la
préparation des résultats du tableau
vous pouvez avoir directement un
graphique des coefficients à ce niveau
là où vous pouvez avoir recours à gg
coeff modèle est voulu passer votre
modèle qui s'y est mode 1
et puis on l'indiqué exponentielle
et donc vous voyez on arrive c'est juste
le soupçon par défaut sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes
là vous avez la colorisation des
différentes variables qui apparaît on
voit quand même un qui a une varier les
variables condé effet c'est quand même
le niveau de résidence le sexe de
l'enfant mais la variable rang après
idéal les autres bon ça a pas l'air
d'avoir des gros gros est fait et donc
du coup comme on l'avait fait pour un
modèle de régression logistique
nous pouvons essayer de simplifier le
modèle par minimisation des lycées avec
la fonction step
donc on va faire un deuxième modèle qui
va être un modèle réduit à partir de
step mode 1 et voyez ça va nous
simplifier le modèle vous avez ici
toutes les étapes pour été faites donc
comme on a des variables ont été retirés
étape par étape et voyez que les trois
variables qui reste à la fin c'est roi
près des halles milieu et sexe sur
lequel et dont peu pareil faire le
graphique des coefficients pour voir ce
qu'il en est on a un modèle un peu plus
léger un kir a gardé du coup les trois
variables les plus significatives voyez
ici que rang après idéal
il est juste présenté comme le nom de la
variable pas quelque chose de propre
simplement parce que précédemment nous
n'avons pas donné des tic est de
variables si je voulais avoir quelque
chose de
de plus propre là où j'ai créé rend
après idéal après des écrits à quel
endroit de mon code ici peut-être que ce
qu'on aurait dû faire c'est un cette
variable label on va lui donner bon cran
après idéal est égal
[Musique]
je donne une étiquette en français et
donc du coup si j'exécute toute la fin
de mon code il faut le faire avant le
calcul des modèles mettre les étiquettes
mais si on met les étiquettes de
variables avant calcul du modèle en fait
avant se propager tout du long de
l'analyse et du coup dans les tableaux
qui sont faits avec jti somalie ou dans
les graphiques qui sont faits avec gégé
coeff modèle vous allez retrouver les
étiquettes et on va la vendre et le voir
dans quelques instants le temps que tous
leurs calculs
et donc si on regarde du coup le dernier
graphique produits voyez ici
les informations sont récupérées alors
pour vous dire aussi que l'extension sur
surf myners qui fournit des dd on l'a
vue d un régisseur qui fournit un son se
ce gie soeur pelote pour le graphique
des capelans par ailleurs fournit aussi
une fonction qui s'appelle jeff forrest
modèle gg forêt ce pardon alors qu'ils
ne qui ne marche qu'avec les modèles de
coques ça ne marche pas avec des
régressions du stick ou des modèles
classiques
à la différence de ggf modèle qui marche
au tout type de modèle mais ce gg forest
la californie avec sauf myners vous
propose aussi une présentation alors un
petit peu différente
voyez mais vous avez à la fois les
l'élaboration représenter selon une
échelle une échelle
expo logist est logarithmique et vous
avez en fait à la fois l'épée valeur sur
le côté et un certain nombre
d'informations qui sont indiqués et les
aberrations qui sont indiqués ici en
valeur la gazette une autre présentation
mais voyez j'ai foiré se parle on ne
prend pas en compte les étiquettes des
variables mais c'est pour vous dire
qu'il ya souvent plusieurs manières
d'aborder les choses
reste à savoir à un moment donné si si
votre modèle est valide il tout à
l'heure un modèle de cox repose sur
l'hypothèse de la proportionnalité des
risques là en l'occurrence c'est à dire
que le risque des femmes est multiplié
par 0 44 par rapport aux risques des
hommes
oui on fait l'hypothèse que c'est donc
que ces deux tiers en moins c / 3
s'applique à toutes les étapes du temps
c'est à dire entre 0 et 60 - qui a duré
l'analyse donc cette proportionnalité
des risques ou du moins ce qu'on appelle
proportionnalité des risques relatifs
on parle de l'hypothèse que ça ne dépend
pas du temps et ça ça peut se vérifier
parce que selon cette hypothèse qu'on
appelle les résidus de schönefeld ne
dépendent pas du temps et on peut tester
cela alors on peut faire le test avec la
fonction cox point z ph à laquelle je
vais y passer mon modèle dont je passais
mon modèle mode deux d'accord voyons
voir déjà ce que nous donne le test on
est dans la
on va tester la validité du modèle
voyons voir ce que ça me dis qu'est ce
que ça nous dit donc là on va regarder
les petits pets un pour chacune des
variables et si jamais en fait ce conte
scs que les résidus de shon fil des
pommes du temps donc ce qu'on cherche
csip est inférieure à 0,5 donc six pay
est inférieure à 5% ça veut dire que les
résidus dépendent du temps et donc
l'hypothèse n'est pas vérifiée et donc
le modèle ne serait pas valide
là toutes nos pelles valeurs sont
supérieurs à 5% donc on ne peut pas en
déduire que nos résidus de jeunes fils
dépendent du temps donc a priori nos
hypothèses sont vérifiées on peut aussi
et toujours avec save myners qui nous
propose une fonction qui est gg cox êtes
ph pour représente donc j'y passe le
résultat de coqs 7.7 ph
et donc si je lui passe ça ça va nous
représenter de manière visuelle
les résidus jon field alors je vais vous
agrandir le graphique
donc vous avez les les résidus
représenté en haut de leur écart et le
temps donc nous ce qu'on cherche c'est
ce que les résidus soit autour de zéro
ça soit à peu près équilibré ce qui
serait problématique si jamais été très
négatif au premier temps et devenait
positif après c'est à dire qu'on est
quelque chose qui qui dépendent du temps
là ce n'est pas le cas vous voyez c'est
parfaitement linéaire à cet endroit là
et vous avez en même temps les valeurs
des 3 p donc encore une fois on est dans
une situation plutôt positive dont les
résidus ne dépendent pas du thon
alors on va s'arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui on aura vu un
c'est vraiment une introduction à
l'analyse survie parce qu'après vous
avez des modèles de plus en plus
compliqué avec censure à droite sur la
gauche vous avez des ddd type plus
complexes et puis aussi ont pu être
développé des des modèles de survie
multi est un ou des modèles de survie à
risque compétitif ceci étant dit au cas
où vous ayez des données qui sont
pondérées ce qu'elle cas souvent éclairé
des enquêtes avec des plans
d'échantillonnage complexe nous avions
fait tout une vidéo sur le plan
d'échantillonnage complexe sachez que
vous avez dans le package servaient les
fonctions qui permettent de faire une
analyse de survie avec un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe plus
spécifiquement avec sbk m qui permet de
réaliser du coup un kaplan meier pondéré
mais également avec du coup les les
éléments nécessaires et vous avez
également sv y cox ph qui permet de
réaliser le modèle de survie mais adapté
au plan d'échantillonnage complexe donc
encore une fois on peut avec le package
sauvé complexifier les choses je le
regarde du coup s'il ya juste quelques
toute dernière question avant qu'on
s'arrête là pour ce soir notamment une
question de cédric sur comment présenter
la contribution des variables
explicatives
alors je sais pas si ce que vous voulez
dire exactement par contributions ce qui
est à retenir c'est qu'on va présenter
les résultats on va présenter
les résultats du modèle comme on
présente rennes une régression
logistique
autrement dit si je si je prends les
résultats de notre notre modèle qui
porte sur la mortalité
la mortalité est moins importante pour
les enfants de sexe féminin et plus
spécifiquement les si je retourne plus
tôt sur le tableau ou sur le forrest on
a aussi les valeurs du cou qui sont
indiqués pour les enfants de sexe
féminin
on a à z ratio de 0.44 a donc c'est à
dire en fait 66 % donc on peut dire deux
tiers en moins la probité pour les
femmes de décéder entre 0 en fait à
chaque moment du temps la probabilité
les 2 66% de moins pour les femmes que
pour les garçons de la même manière à
chaque moment du temps la probabilité de
décéder
pour un enfant en milieu rural est une
ville cinq fois plus élevé que pour un
enfant en milieu urbain toutes autres
choses égales par ailleurs
et enfin lorsqu'un enfant naît à un rang
élevé c'est-à-dire plus élevé que
l'idéal pour la mère il a une
probabilité décider qui est bien plus
élevé inquiets de ils ont trois fois et
demi plus de risques de décéder qu'un
enfant qui est qui pour une mère qui n'a
pas encore dépassé son idéal du nombre
d'enfants donc c'est les cds hazard
ratio savas interprétées comme des
prévalences raciaux comme des incidents
ce ratio
donc c'est de l'interprétation du modèle
va être vraiment équivalente je vous
propose qu'on s'arrête là pour ce soir
je vous remercie jean même si celles et
ceux qui continuent à suivre le
webinaire en live et qui qui ont ce
courage là je sais que vous êtes aussi
nombreux à regarder les webinaires en
différé et donc du coup je vous souhaite
sur un bon visionnage
et puis on se retrouvera du coup
prochainement pour un tout nouveau
webinaire et la prochaine session
devrait porter sur l'analyse de
séquences en sciences humaines et
sociales
merci à tous très bonne soirée bon
courage dans vos apprentissages surtout
n'hésitez pas à compléter avec la
lecture du site analyse air et à très
bientôt
au revoir